[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça
porte malheur
on commence comme chaque semaine avec
tout ce qui s'est passé pendant les pubs
pendant les love pendant les magnétos ça
s'appelle La Gazette
et on commence par Daniel qui a tenté
une nouvelle petite peucou très moderne
regardez elle a pas la coupe de
Jean-Pierre Foucault
[Musique]
dans le public bah je peux compter sur
vous merci beaucoup
la discrétion Cyril on continue avec le
retour du Grand Bernard
[Musique]
il y a quelques jours il y a eu une
table un peu spéciale avec des
chroniqueurs que les téléspectateurs ont
moi l'habitude de boire mais visiblement
Lionel Messi le directeur général de
votre société CYRIL a lui aussi moins
l'habitude de les voir
j'ai jamais pu le faire
et quand vous êtes fatigué et bien il
écoute les conseils des médecins ça
c'est bien mais il fait lui-même ça
prend de l'eau
vitamine C vitamine D il a dit le
docteur
parce que j'ai pas été invité
[Musique]
je fais une grosse soirée moi
je suis une grosse soirée
samedi soir malheureusement j'ai tout le
monde annuler par contre tu peux
peut-être passer
en tout cas Mathieu comme d'hab c'est
accueillir les petits nouveaux avec sa
simplicité légendaire c'est noir
rien n'est blanc hein
et on termine avec l'intervention
efficace de la semaine elle est saignée
vraiment on s'en fout qu'est-ce qu'on
s'en fout ça je vais communiquer sur des
succès c'est la vieille télé c'est
exactement regarde moi qui suis extrait
alors Léa Drucker bonsoir donc
j'embrasse mon Jean-Pierre Foucault on
va retrouver le 17 décembre
et Rizlaine était top très sympathique
en place
si vous étiez très souffrant cette
semaine souffrance ça va et comme vous
aviez la flemme tous les jours
avait la flemme de s'envoyer un arrêt
maladie à lui-même qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait il est venu présenter l'émission
lui-même comme Warrior il se croit
mythique il se croit au-dessus de la
nature sauf que parfois bien la nature
vous rattrape j'ai un petit conseil pour
moi un bon médicament ça s'appelle
l'amoxicilline c'est pour moi c'est
cadeau on regarde
découvrez amoxicilline pour guérir de la
grippe en un jour seulement c'était
vigilant ensemble
un jour je l'ai défoncé un jour
portons le masque dès que nous sommes
fragile je suis une bête un jour la
grippe un jour pas de hein pas deux hein
ça va mes amours
[Rires]
[Musique]
Cyril parce que c'est pas ce qu'on
autant écoutez bien votre voix qui part
en sucette je suis libre la grippe j'ai
eu un jour j'ai eu un jour je suis une
bête je suis une bête humique la grippe
j'ai eu un jour je suis mythique Meetic
Meetic plutôt à l'article de la crise
d'asthme chien
musiques
j'ai vu quelques jours TPMP a accueilli
un chroniqueur qu'on a tous un
chroniqueur exceptionnel une belle paire
de Jean-Marie Bigard Jean-Marie Bigard
j'ai failli partir en gros mots et je me
suis dit c'est ça tout simplement comme
ça
au-delà de son humour direct
au-delà je reprends ma fiche au-delà de
son humour et de cette très bonne manne
Jean-Marie c'est un peu le tonton de
l'équipe et vous savez quel est son
secret vous savez quel est son secret
les six commandements il est assis
commandements regardez on en parle après
[Musique]
de la répartie tu auras
ta femme elle est bien aussi
ce que les gens savent pas de quoi on
parle non je suis vraiment te montrer la
paix
tu t'en battras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
idée et tout merci
bonne élève tu seras
et donc il doit à ses actionnaires enfin
à ceux avec qui il a monté ce réseau
social une exclusivité
tu sauras très souvent de la vraie
semaine surtout notre grand-père Marcel
on a bouffé beaucoup trop vieux bon Dieu
c'était en a goûté grand-mère
[Musique]
ma sœur avait un goût Americ
[Applaudissements]
perspicace du seras
keresa
vers le bas
observateur tu seras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une couille
le petit bout de chair qui
les gars
[Musique]
j'ai un dernier magnéto parce que je
pouvais pas partir sans en mettre un
petit peu comment pour que vous créez le
manque comme ça la semaine prochaine
Cyril vous savez que lorsqu'il est avec
Mathieu normault est-ce que d'ailleurs
c'est votre ami Mathieu Delormeau au
final vous avez pas tranché il coûte en
tout cas ce n'est pas un ennemi c'est
pas un ennemi non non parce que on est
mon frère
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai 4 amis
proche de vous et ben on va voir le
magnéto qui va suivre et je pense que
l'amitié enfin mon frère c'est plutôt
dans un sens
tu vois tu as raison
chérie ça marche puisque même moi j'ai
acheté tous les mauvais papiers sur toi
donc maman n'achète pas ça parce que
plus on achète plus en fonte bah oui bah
oui tu me connais tu me vois tout le
temps
l'amitié c'est que dans un sens avec
Mathieu j'ai l'impression
alors qu'après toi
c'est un gars une fille mais que
[Musique]
j'ai un pote qui est trop mignon ça
devient plein à toi
[Musique]
j'ai envie de te mettre une part dans la
gueule
[Musique]
et si je faisais le jeu de 30 secondes
pour demander ah ouais je te le
recommande jamais de la musique
[Musique]
c'est vraiment les blagues non mais on
va lui faire combien d'années ces
blagues là combien d'années voilà voilà
mais tous les antibiotiques et tout on
dit plus épices efficace par l'anus
quand tu es malade un suppo il y a rien
de plus efficace je te jure
j'en mets deux trois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah là là